vor sieben wochen hat einer unserer
gäste hier am ersten philosophischen
stammtisch das buch coaching kapital von
peter dirk empfohlen eine philosophische
analyse der offshore geschäfte niemand
von uns hätte damals gedacht dass dieser
titel über nacht dermaßen aktuell werden
würde
die panama papers haben gezeigt dass
eine grundsatzdiskussion über
steuerwettbewerb dringend nötig ist und
genau die wollen wir heute liefern in
unserem zweiten philosophischen
stammtisch herzlich willkommen
neben den panama papers steht auch die
affäre böhmermann auf dem programm um
die frage wie mit satire heute politik
gemacht wird
unsere stammgäste sind wiederum kathrin
mark aus berlin philosophin und
kulturjournalistin und hier ist auch
wieder unser stammgast konrad paul
liessmann professor für philosophie von
der universität wien mit am tisch sitzt
heute auch mirjam rund sony die an der
universität manchester
politische philosophie lehrt um zu
fragen der globalen gerechtigkeit und
zum steuerwettbewerb arbeitet herzlich
willkommen ihnen allen
ja wir ihnen hier also mit den panama
paper sein netzwerk von journalisten hat
daten von 214.000 briefkastenfirmen in
panama veröffentlicht zu den profiteuren
zählen auch staats und regierungschefs
politiker und spitzensportler frau und
sony sie beschäftigen sich mit fragen
der ethik im zusammenhang mit
steuerwettbewerb 214.000
briefkastenfirma geleitet von einer
einzigen agentur aus erstaunte die zahl
der vielen dank für die frage also erst
mal ich entschuldige mich im voraus für
die grammatikfehler und für den akzent
womit ich euch heute amüsieren werde ich
bin ursprünglich italienerin
nein das ausmaß überrascht mich nicht
es gibt viele forscher vor allem gabriel
sucht mann aus bald die seit jahren
versuchen zu rechnen
selbstverständlich ist sehr kompliziert
weil es keine öffentliche ressourcen
geht das ist genau das problem
wir versuchen zu rechnen wie viel geld
eigentlichen steueroasen steckt und wie
viel geld dadurch steuer ämter verlieren
und das ist ziemlich klar
es ist ein massives phänomen deswegen
überrascht es mich eigentlich nicht
viele beobachter würden davon überrascht
wie wenig die situation sich geändert
hat nach der finanzkrise gab es viele
versuchen das thema offensiv anzugehen
und auch viele bilaterale und
multilaterale übereinkommen und trotzdem
hat sich nicht so viel verändert kathrin
numark es wurde ja es hat sich nicht
viel geändert haben sie gesagt was ich
auch nicht verändert hat ist dass die
sache noch nicht jetzt wirklich illegal
geworden ist und tatsächlich haben viele
darauf hingewiesen auf schau geschäfte
sind nach wie vor in vielen bereichen
legal aber trotzdem vielleicht nicht
legitim viele haben gesagt nein
natürlich ist trotzdem unmoralisch wie
sehen sie das
ja also zumal ich finde auch man muss
diesen unterschied zu ziehen und man
kann sagen also ich glaube
geschäftsmodelle die darauf basieren
dass man in dem start in dem man lebt
keine steuern oder zu wenig steuern
bezahlt also dessen infrastruktur man
nutzt sich also sozusagen
entsolidarisiert mit der gesellschaft
der mann angehört die halte ich nicht
für legitim und es ist dann eher ein
problem der gesetzeslage dass sie immer
noch legal sind das würde ich auf jeden
fall so sehen und dann muss man ja auch
sagen dass das schwankt sehr und den
angaben also manche banker sagen ja es
mag einzelne schwarze schafe geben aber
das gros ist natürlich völlig legitim
ist geschäftsgebaren aber es hat mir
noch keiner so richtig viel und gut
erklären können welche wirklich
legitimen legalen zweck solcher
briefkastenfirmen erfüllen können solche
schlupflöcher außer wirklich den zweck
der steuerhinterziehung also es gibt da
scheint mir jetzt nicht so viele
alternativen wozu die wirklich genutzt
werden können darauf werden wir bestimmt
noch kommen herr ließ man was ja
auffällig dass auch oft jetzt gesagt
wird naja es ist wieder typisch der
kleine brave mann zahlt seine steuern
erreiche umgeht sie ist es wirklich so
einfach
mache ja fast geneigt zu sagen ja manche
dinge sind eben so einfach wäre
möglichkeiten hat steuern zu
hinterziehen wird es im möglichkeiten
nutzen wenn es legale möglichkeiten sind
umso lieber weil man ja keine strafen zu
erwarten hat wer sehr viel geld zur
verfügung hat wer sehr reich ist wird
steuerhinterziehung ja überproportional
profitieren
der kleine mann von dem die rede ist mit
einem mittleren einkommen auch wenn er
das ein oder andere nicht angibt was die
meisten wahrscheinlich tun die die
möglichkeit dazu haben oder auch wenn er
seine haushaltshilfe illegal beschäftigt
dass die meisten tun wenn sie die
möglichkeit dazu haben kinder zieht der
gewisser weise auch steuert hält sich
auch unkorrekt aber er hat keine
möglichkeit wird aufgrund seines
einkommens noch aufgrund der
gesetzeslage und er sich befindet im
großen stil das zu machen es gibt länder
wie österreich wo den einkommen von
arbeitern angestellten die steuer
ohnehin gleich von staatswegen abgezogen
wird die frage ist der brav oder nichts
braucht stellt sich gar nicht er hat
keine möglichkeit böse zu sein
wer die möglichkeit hat böse zu sein ist
es auch wer mal ein bisschen nietzsche
gelesen hat kann doch alle diese dinge
überhaupt nicht überrascht sein
ja genau ich glaube was hat man gerade
gesagt hat sturz genau an den wichtigen
punkt nämlich es ist also wie tendieren
vielleicht dazu in panama city sind eine
gewisse art und weise anzugehen die
meiner meinung nach nicht unbedingt die
richtige ist nämlich haben diese
individuen oder dieser individuelle
konzernen etwas moralisch falsches
gemacht dass damit meine ich nicht dass
die frage der legitimität nicht
unbedingt wichtig ist sie ist wichtig
aber ich würde sagen es ist ein
strukturelles problem deswegen die frage
am anfang das ausmaß das ist für mich
wichtig weil ausmaß macht ein
unterschied also quantität kann zu einem
qualitativen problem ist dass er für
mich ist das problem nicht diese
menschen und dieser konzerne haben was
moralisch falsches gemacht sondern wie
viele von diesen individuen konzernen
das machen und was für strukturelle
probleme das verursacht
was für strukturelle anreize dafür aber
sagt selbstverständlich dass
ungleichheiten zwischen reiche menschen
und normale steuerzahler noch wachsen
aber auch andere faktoren das zum
beispiel länder gezwungen sind ihre
struktur radikal umzuwandeln
das sind wir ja eigentlich genau bei der
kernfrage was eigentlich ungerecht ist
auch ein natürlich profitieren staaten
ja auch davon
sie möchte auch darauf hinweisen die
schweiz hat gemäss schätzungen 49.000
briefkastenfirmen
naja es gibt natürlich auch befürworter
und profiteure dieses systems was genau
ist ungerechter raum frau und sony also
ich glaube es gibt zwei arten weise das
problem heranzugehen und dich teile
beide aber ich glaube 1 ist noch
erfolgreicher weil es eigentlich ein
breiteres publikum anziehen könnte es
gibt diejenigen die sagen
steuerwettbewerb und dieser große
mobilität von kapital eigentlich
verursacht große ungleichheiten
eigentlich auch zwischen ländern so
entwicklungsländer eigentlich während
viel deutlicher geschadet von
steuerwettbewerb als reichere länder das
aber million euro pro jahr
acht mal so viel wie die offizielle
entwicklungshilfe die frist ab die genau
genau und und auch innerhalb von ländern
aber wachsen augen gleichheit weil
reiche menschen das machen können und
andere nicht aber auch mal strukturen
sich ändern um das problem ein bisschen
zu lösen und trotzdem irgendwie genug
geld zusammen arbeitet mehr versteht als
kapital konsum mehr als einkommen und
manche würde sagen das ist ungerecht
es gibt es ist ungerecht dass gleichheit
wachsen
ich finde das ist richtig aber ich finde
es ist noch ein grundsätzlicheres
problem und das grundsätzliches problem
ist länder haben keinen spielraum
sie können nicht mehr frei entscheiden
was für ein steuersystem sie haben
wollen und daran ist für mich ein
demokratisches probieren können sie das
nicht mehr freiensteinau hätte
eigentlich sagen das ist eben in der
souveränität eines staates selber über
die steuerquote zu entscheiden
ja das hört mit vielleicht das thema was
wir unter souveränität verstehen und ich
teil ist genauso wie sie so souveränität
heißt so steuersätze zu entscheiden aber
wie zu entscheiden
zu entscheiden nach einer art und weise
die die eigentlich so eine reaktion auf
interne bedürfnisse und demokratische
präferenzen antwortet oder auf eine art
und weise die eigentlich mehr ein
ergebnis von externer druck ist das ist
für mich die entscheidende geschichte
als wäre dann so seien die frage ob ein
staat sich so verhält wie ein business
also wären wirtschaft so seien in einem
wettbewerb von anderen anbietern kann er
die tiefsten steuern anbieten oder
meinen start er sozusagen so etwas wie
eingebildet dass eigener und mögliche
demokratischer fast der natur betrifft
das sozusagen sehr auf die internen
bedürfnisse eingeht dann sind natürlich
auch einfach zwei unterschiedliche
perspektiven also ich meine ist die
richtige ich glaube sie haben natürlich
spielen beide ich finde es ja ich finde
dieses strukturelle perspektive sehr
interessant weil wir tatsächlich ja sehr
dazu tendieren
das von dem individuum das eben böse ist
also amoralisch und wenn es kann dann
wird es auch am moralisch handeln zum
eigenen vorteil also so wird die debatte
ja sehr oft geführt und ich finde
natürlich diese struktur gebracht
die ist genauso zu sein das interessante
daran weil das sozusagen diese es zeigt
eben unter welche sachzwänge staaten
geraten können aber gleichzeitig kann
man nicht auch sagen dass kein staat
wirklich gezwungen ist die das
finanzgeschäft und das geschäft mit
tiefen steuern zu seinem geschäftsmodell
zu machen könnte man ja auch sagen das
wird ja auch in der souveränität von
staaten liegen ließ man ja ich denke wir
haben hier ganze reihe von problemen die
einer die einen sind sich sagen wir
politisch ökonomisch juristischer natur
und hänge auch damit zusammen etwa dass
wir schon widerspruch haben auf der
einen seite zwischen unserer konzeption
des souveränen staates den wir uns
gleichsam im nahezu technischen sinn
jahres geschlossenen handelstag
handelsstadt vorstellen und auf der
anderen seite der von uns ja auch sehr
stark propagierten und befürwortet und
globalisierung ja das ist ein
widerspruch ich kann nichts dazu sagen
das finanzkapital global zig tausend mal
am tag um den erdball
jagen und das euphorisch feiern und dann
tränen darüber vergessen dass der
nationalstaaten in ihrer begrenzt zeit
dass sie keinen zugriff mehr auf dieses
kapital haben das wollten wir ja so wir
haben ja sozusagen permanent also sagen
diese nationalstaatlichen souveränität
wir jetzt im sinne jetzt derjenigen die
sozusagen bekenntnisse zur
globalisierung seit 20 jahren abgeben
das sind vielleicht kann man diskutieren
die frage ist wer jetzt eigentlich
verbrochen hat diesen zustand her aber
es seien weiter zu die titel
globalisierung der finanzmärkte weil er
auf politische entscheidungen die von
demokratisch legitimierten regierungen
getroffen worden sind so war es ja nicht
ja und das jetzt sozusagen es nicht
möglich ist bestimmte finanzplätze
trockenzulegen die wirklich am rande
oder jenseits der legalität sicher
befinden ist auch entscheidungen von
demokratisch legitimierten regierungen
in london oder anderswo
aber das ist der eine punkt der ich
denke es ist das aber ein struktureller
widerspruch es hat schon auch mit der
funktion des staates zu tun
der andere philosophische punkt würde
nicht gerne bisserl diskutieren auch
würde die philosophische frage ist ja
sozusagen die grundsätzliche was sind
steuern überhaupt ja und wozu die frage
stellt hierzu nehmen also gar keine
steuern
also ich glaube wenn man ehrlich ist
sagte niemand gern steuern ja dann im
grunde heißt das im grunde heißt das
dass ich nicht nur nicht nur ich aber es
gibt auch ziemlich solide
sozialwissenschaftliche forschung
gezeigt es gibt länder wo leute wirklich
gerne bezahlen unproblematischer
folglich aus ja also die beispiele sind
die üblichen verdächtigen nämlich
skandinavischen ländern aber zum
beispiel ein politikwissenschaftler aus
schweden hat gezeigt wenn leute wirklich
ziemlich klar sehen wofür steuer gedacht
doch dann wollte ich auch genau jeden
tag also wenn man in einem einigermaßen
sicheren europäischen land lebt wo der
öffentliche nahverkehr einigermaßen gut
funktioniert die straßen einigermaßen
sauber sind da sieht man doch jeden tag
wofür die stadt die man zahlt sind ich
lebe ja als schweizerin nun jetzt schon
länger in deutschland da wird man ja
auch mit sozialleistungen überschüttet
etwa wenn man kinder bekommt
ich sehe sehr genau wofür die sind die
steuern nicht zahlen und ich finde sie
auch relativ hoch das ist in deutschland
leider so aber ich sehe auch was wo sie
wiederum kommt also nicht ins tor
natürlich man muss auch unterscheiden
man kann ja etwas einsehen dass
vernünftig ist gerade weil man eben in
einer gesellschaft leben will in der
bestimmte dinge funktioniert das
funktionieren in der öffentliche
leistungen angeboten werden in der ein
sozialstaat existiert und man weiß
natürlich dass man jetzt da zu seinem
beitrag leisten soll
das bedeutete nicht dass man das gerne
macht denn natürlich bedeutet der
anderen seite das einen teil als ein
teil des einkommens dem man sich ja
erarbeitet hat der mann verdient hat
dann muss man mal abgeben
aufpassen es folgendes das große problem
warum wir auch sozusagen hier
moralischen siebel reagieren auf diese
geschichten der panama peters und da
briefkastenfirmen besteht der genau
darin dass wir zunehmend das gefühl
haben dass diejenigen die sozusagen im
mittleren einkommensbereich sind und
keine möglichkeiten kreativer
steuervermeidung haben dass die immer
mehr diese lasten zu tragen haben die
sozusagen auf der anderen seite von den
sich in wenigen händen kontinenten
vermögen oder dass man überhaupt nicht
mehr tangiert werden und ich glaube das
verschafft dieses gefühl der
ungerechtigkeit und da kann man sich
schon mal die frage stellen sich sehr
aufgeworfen warum wird arbeit so hoch
besteuert rum wird vermögen so niedrig
besteuert warum es in europa noch immer
nicht geschafft was ganz vernünftiges im
untersten promille bereich einzurichten
haben eine finanztransaktionssteuer
woher sozusagen diese tendenz zu sagen
wir bestimmte tätigkeiten bestimmte
verhaltensweisen und bestimmte form von
produktivität hoch zu besteuern und eine
andere gleichsam außen vor zu lassen
also ich wollte zwei punkte machen ich
glaube wir haben das thema souveränität
ein bisschen zu schnell zur seite
gelassen und ich wollte zwei beispiele
machen die eu am anfang und das bretton
woods über einkommen und ich glaube in
beiden fällen ging es darum ja auch
märkte zu öffnen und sand statt zu
machen aber nicht als höchste priorität
sondern instrument
genauso viele öffnen wie es eigentlich
die problemlösungsfähigkeit von
verschiedenen demokratien hilft also
aktuellsten dass diese fließt ja einfach
auch global hierhin sondern hat
natürliche bretten sitz instrumente
geschaffen ein bisschen zu regulieren
genau und in der eu ging es nicht genau
die gleichen sachen sei verständlich
kapitals verkehrskontrolle waren nicht
die hohe priorität da aber da also auch
der gemeinsame markt war instrumentell
gesehen und nicht alles intrinsische
zwecke also die idee war
wir kommen zusammen und wir schaffen
auch regelt die uns ein bisschen zwingen
aber also damit wir innerhalb von diesen
regeln eigentlich mehr konkrete freiheit
haben eigentlich mehr spiele haben und
ich glaube diese mentalität haben wir
ein bisschen zu schnell hinter uns
gelassen und vielleicht ist es wirklich
zeit wieder zu denken regulierung ist
wirklich nicht nur an last aber wie
können wir das wieder attraktiv machen
lassen sie mich noch einen punkt
einfügen interessant ist ja dass gerade
die schweiz ein steuerwettbewerb auch
kennt zwischen den kantonen
und es gibt natürlich einen großen
streit darüber ob das ein sinnvolles
instrument ist oder nicht aber die
befürworter sagen immer na ja das dient
natürlich dazu zu regulieren dass die
staatskasse da nicht mit geld um sich
wirft also dass ich im grunde genommen
ein probates mittel um starts kosten
niedrig zu halten
was sagen sie dazu beim steuerwettbewerb
nicht auch dazu dienen dafür zu sorgen
dass der staatshaushalt gegen die da
nicht so ausgabefreudig wird aber wird
also wie funktioniert denn das argument
warum würde der steuerwettbewerb das
verhindern dass der staatshaushalt also
wenn man sozusagen helden bereiten
kanton weiß dann nachbarkantonen haben
verlangt weniger steuern
almeida zum beispiel effizienter
arbeitet kann er das tun also bin ich
selber gezwungen effizient zu arbeiten
und leute die sich damit beschäftigen
machen normalerweise eine unterscheidung
zwischen schädlichen steuerwettbewerb
und normale zum beispiel es gibt auch
eine art steuerwettbewerb vorüber wären
überhaupt nicht gesprochen habe
heute und die eigentlich zu den panama
liegt nicht gehört und das ist stahl
wettbewerben da nicht nur völlig legal
ist aber die meisten würden sagen auch
völlig legitim nämlich nicht
briefkastenfirmen ins land zu locken
sondern richtige echte institution
investitionen entschuldigung ich glaube
selbst diese art steuerwettbewerb sollte
man vermutlich unter umständen ein
bisschen zu verlangsamen nicht zu
blockieren aber zu verlangsamen aber das
thema ist keine ist gegen wettbewerb
punkt und kann er es auch nicht
unbedingt gegen steuerwettbewerb punkt
aber eben ich würde zurück zu den slogan
gehen quantität schafft irgendwann
qualitativer probleme wenn es zu viel zu
schnell
und dazu führt dass kapital einfach die
macht hat staaten und öffentlicher
bevölkerungen und demokratische
bevölkerung den druck zu setzen
dann muss etwas dagegen gemacht wird
nicht um steuerwettbewerb ganz zu
schließen aber einfach mehr
gleichgewicht zu schaffen und sie sich
die frage was tut man dagegen sie
verlangen mehr regulierung frauen zone
sie haben das auch in einem interview
zum ausdruck gebracht dass sie es kultur
im vorfeld gegeben haben es gibt
unterschiedliche ideen wie man
regulieren könnte interessant ist aber
über staatliche vorstellungen dessen die
wir da gerecht mit einer wirtschaften
könnten
die haben ja gerade ihnen die schlechte
karten überhaupt über staatliches denken
das haben sicher ließ man auch gesagt
wir stehen vor einem drohenden braig
sieht darüber wird zurzeit auch heiß
diskutierte man kriegt den eindruck die
staaten raufen sich im moment nicht
gerade sehr erfolgreich zusammen was
eigentlich ein bisschen ein vorschlag
zur zeigt ja ist es dann aber nicht auch
einfach so dass wir generell auf jeder
ebene auf der eu ebene sowie auf der
globalen ebene
das sehen dass wir sozusagen
globalisierung internationalisierung
befürwortet haben aber das eben die
wirtschaft da sehr viel schneller war
als die politik und die politiker sie
dermaßen in dem masse im hintertreffen
ist und eigentlich da einfach nicht
mithalten kann und natürlich auch
einfach nicht mit der ausstattung
unterwegs ist die wirtschaftlichen
verhältnisse haben sich einfach sehr
viel schneller verändert als die
politischen die politische ist eher
umgekehrt dass wir jetzt wieder
unglaublich nationalstaatlich anfangen
zu denken gerade im zuge der
flüchtlingskrise kann man das ja auch
wieder sehen also das ist so
ein komponieren gibt doch diese art von
rechtspopulismus und da sehe ich ja
schon einen widerspruch darin dass wir
gleichzeitig wirtschafts theoretisch
diese sehr starke globalisierung
befürworten und aber mit unserer politik
überhaupt nicht da hinterher sind also
ich das ist sozusagen eigentlich das
problem was ich in diesen panama papers
ja eigentlich letztlich oft was sind sie
sind die politik getragen werden
es gibt ganz sicher ungleichzeitigkeiten
ja und sozusagen asynchrone
geschwindigkeiten in diesem feld von
politik wirtschaft & soziales
wir haben sozusagen internationale
finanzwirtschaft und kapital
verkehrsströme die relativ großzügig und
frei sind und sehr schnell geschehen
können aber auch innerhalb europas
innerhalb der eu sollen die
sozialstaatlichen regeln
die steuerrechtlichen regelungen sind
nach wie vor eher national bestimmt da
wir haben europäische steuer rechte
haben europäische sozialrecht deswegen
kann auch schon passion währungsfrage
die frage welche sozialleistungen keinen
start bieten auch zu solch einem
wettbewerber von einer anderen ebene
führen
aber es werden lässig als gesellschaften
gesellschaftlicher immer noch in diesen
nationalstaaten erzählen ich als auch in
der solidarität das richtig dass wir
denken nicht nur denken thomas
vielleicht gar nicht so sehr sondern in
der realität leben wir denn deswegen
können wir auch sagen bin die einen ihre
steuern hinterziehen oder nicht zahlen
können weil es eine briefkastenfirma in
panama oder in delaware oder sonstwo
haben ja aber die anderen die hier leben
hier sozial bedürftig sind hier beim
verbraucher von jenen die hier arbeiten
denn einfach die steuern abgezogen wird
dann entsteht genau diese form von
asynchron ideen anlass das heißt die
gemeinschaft der einsatz noch die
gemeinschaft der deren solidarität
steuert so eine steuer ethisch plausibel
erscheinen lässt ist im kleine
weltgemeinschaft noch nicht
lassen sie mich hier auf einen punkt den
gleisen fifa und sony haben ihren
interview gesagt sie glauben wir
brauchen so was sie eine transnationale
politische lösung und teil dieses
formates ist ja immer auch das
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer uns fragen
stellen können und ihre ideen schicken
und sie möchte hier ein
frage einbringen der zuschauer ja und
steinmann fragt nämlich genau zu diesem
punkt wie genau stellen sie sich vor und
sony die mobilisierung eines politischen
willens vor durch die wahrgenommen die
verantwortung der intellektuellen oder
durch die gründung einer bewegung die
occupy genau ich glaube das ist genau
der wichtigste punkt und es gibt einen
eigentlich ziemlich klarer zusammenhang
mit den letzten zwei interventionen
nämlich ich glaube ich stimme zu
globalisierung und es ist schneller
gewesen als politische integration
aber bis zu einem gewissen grad also ich
glaube die andere seite der geschichte
es gibt eigentlich transnationale und
supranationale politisierung aber in
anführungsstrichen der falschen art und
weise also doch es geht
es gibt globale und internationale
regeln aber die ganz die ganz klare
bestimmte interesse dienen und die
demokratisch nicht so kontrollieren
sowie internationale handlungsort anisa
zion oder auch wie die eu mit mitte
krisen der letzten fünf oder sechs
jahren umgegangen sind
wieso und die zuschauer schlossen ich
frage das zuschauer sind also henrik
müller hat neulich im spiegel
geschrieben es ist ein desaster
wir wir leben in einer zeit des
nationalismus und eigentlich brauchen
der globale lösung stimmt wir brauchen
globale lösung aber wir brauchen globale
lösung die eigentlich von unten kommen
die eigentlich demokratisches im punkt
haben also für mich die einzige lösung
und ich bin da nicht optimistisch ich
glaube nicht es geht morgen passieren
über die einzige lösung ist genau eine
transnationale bewegung also es reicht
nicht dass ein land einfach das beispiel
nimmt nimmt aber gleichzeitig kann es
nicht von oben kommen also ist keine
frage von ideale police ideale politik
maßnahmen die von von experten umgesetzt
so kipper von unten aber auch
transnationale es muss also genug druck
in einem genügenden anzahl von ländern
geben um wirklich druck auf bestimmte
transnationale lösungen die eigentlich
demokratie
für alle ein bisschen gleicher machen
und nicht unbedingt nochmal
marktwirtschaft sanfter machen und die
aber aus diesem transnationalen druck
kommt ich sage es nicht es wird morgen
passieren
aber für mich gibt es keine andere
lösung und was wäre die vorstellung dass
ein staat sozusagen eine vorbildfunktion
übernimmt also in der schweiz ist gerade
eigentlich dass das gegenteil diskutiert
worden der bundesrat ueli maurer hat
gesagt die schweiz soll jetzt nicht
vorpreschen und sich nicht aus ober
moralisierung der welt auf spielen sie
einen ähnlichen vorwurf eigentlich den
mann angela merkel macht jetzt in der
flüchtlingskrise hat man auch gesagt
moralisieren und moralinsaure päpstin
und so weiter was ist denn die rolle
eines staates es gibt so was wie die
vorbildfunktion eines staates also ich
halte staaten nicht die moralische
instanzen wirklich nicht das inhaltlich
so wie wir mit thomas hobbes starten sie
die situationen die ganz bestimmtes
konfliktlösung potenzial bereitstellen
sollen die sicherheit garantieren sollen
die rahmenbedingungen garantieren sollen
die sozusagen individuelle
entfaltungsmöglichkeiten bieten die auch
wenn irgendwie möglich dazu da sind
kriege zu vermeiden
aber das ist sozusagen jetzt nicht in
dem sinn eine moralische instanz als
entspricht also ganz den interessen von
menschen oder bestimmten gruppierungen
aber was natürlich schon sehr möglich
ist ja das würde ich das als ergänzung
sagen zu dem was sie gesagt haben was
möglich ist dass starten sagen es liegt
einfach hin und dann in unserem
interesse ja zb weil wir ein interesse
daran haben sozial staatlichen
einrichtungen
zu finanzieren wenn interesse daran
haben sozusagen eine infrastruktur
aufrecht zu erhalten liegt im internet
ist das eben nicht gewaltige summen von
geldern die in diesem staat
erwirtschaftet worden sähen hier nicht
versteuert sehen sondern jemanden
anderen zu gute kommen
und es gibt ja auch die theorie oder so
wirtschaftlich starke ein politisch
starke staaten wird weil die
bundesrepublik deutschland durchaus
druck machen kann auf solche kleinen
staaten im positiven sinn wann genau es
heißt es gebe schon auch so sagen
internationale politische möglichkeiten
hierzu eine gesetzgebung zu kommen die
diese form globaler steuervermeidung ist
erzieherin war das wäre dann schon
kriminell oder globaler steuervermeidung
also zumindest ein bisschen einbremst es
kommt schon noch etwas dazu weil sie zu
recht gesagt haben dieser das
internationale die linzer dimension
betrifft ja dass gerade aus den
entwicklungsländern also unvorstellbare
große summen die dort versteuert werden
müssten dort nicht versteuern werden
aber die europäischen staaten mit
denjenigen mit der besteuerten arbeit
die hier sozusagen geleistet wird dann
versuchen das zu kompensieren indem sie
entwicklungshilfe leisten und da wird's
irgendwann einmal wird das doppelt geht
hier ab ich wollte noch mal zu dieser
staatlichen vorbildfunktion also ich
glaube auch nicht dass staaten per se
vorbilder sind es sind vielleicht eher
so einzelne akteure innerhalb von
staaten also ihn bei frau merkel was ja
auch irgendwie frau merkel die sozusagen
geliebt und gehasst wurde für wie sie
die flüchtlingskrise zunächst mal
bewältigt hat aber ich glaube dass
tatsächlich also die frage die wir
vielleicht noch gar nicht so ganz klar
gefasst haben ist ja letztlich und die
geht auch in die richtung vorbild ist
was für ein verhältnis denken wir uns
eigentlich zwischen individuum und
startet also ist der staat sozusagen
dass das gegen das ich bin also
sozusagen diese ganz alte
obrigkeitsstaatliche linie dass man
denkt der staat ist im prinzip der der
mich deckelt solange ich mich da soweit
ich mich dem entziehen kann umso besser
ist es also eine liberale antithese zu
sozusagen absolutistischen die
monarchischen staaten oder ist der staat
eben nichts anderes als die gemeinschaft
ist der start sind total abstrakter
begriff wenn man natürlich ich finde
auch bei den steuern muss man doch eher
denken was sind wir für eine
gesellschaft also wird
das ist ja so eine solidargemeinschaft
ist wie bei versicherung ich zahle was
eigentlich bekommt was zurück und wenn
man sich sozusagen als gemeinschaft als
politische zivilgesellschaft begreift
und da glaube ich schon dass man
durchaus auch auf nationaler ebene
sinnvolle regelungen machen kann und die
natürlich hoffentlich sozusagen als
modellfall dann auch in gewisser weise
globalisieren kann sei das jetzt mit
druck aber letztlich geht es schon darum
wer ich mich als teil die sich wenn man
mal in die tiefe bohrt bei allen fragen
sind sophie stadt kann man so ganz
grundsätzlichen sachen warum überhaupt
steuern was ist eigentlich ein staat ein
ganz kurze antwort von ihr noch vor und
sony was ist da steht ja also ich glaube
für mich was wirklich wichtig ist was
sowas dann geht ist auch was staat also
die beziehungen zwischen status
individuen ist nicht immer das gleiche
und hier könnten könnten wir uns ewig
unterhalten aber wenn wir wirklich etwas
über dieses thema sagen wollen es wir
dürfen nicht unterschätzen
repräsentativen demokratien waren nie
perfekt aber heutzutage sind sie
wirklich in keinem gesunden zustand also
auch in liberalen demokratien sind
normale menschen normale steuerzahler
nicht in der lage so wirklich ihre
institutionen unter demokratischen
kontrolle zu haben und am anfang habe
ich gesagt wir müssten nicht so viel auf
individuelle handlungen von diesem
menschen die geld in steueroasen aber
habe die gleiche menschen die das machen
sind auch die gleiche menschen die
überwiegend macht haben das zu
verursachen dass die regeln sich nicht
ändern
also das ist entscheidend die eu
politisch nicht aber als politische
akteure als politische akteure und
deswegen ist es für mich vernünftiger zu
sagen da druck muss von unten kommen
also wir müssen nicht unbedingt denken
dass die interesse oder die agenda von
staaten im moment die unbedingt so klar
die agenda von ihrer bürger ist das
nehme ich als schlusswort zu diesem
ersten teil kommen die ihr zu unserem
zweiten thema heute nämlich zur affäre
böhmermann was schnell gedicht über den
türkischen präsidenten erdogan dass der
deutsche kabarettist jan böhmermann im
zdf vorgetragen hat hat sich in
deutschland ja mittlerweile zur
staatsaffäre
ausgeweitet für kontroversen sorgte
insbesondere dass kanzlerin angela
merkel die deutsche justiz letzte woche
ermächtigt hat gegen böhme mann wegen
beleidigung des türkischen
staatspräsidenten zu ermitteln
im ergebnis wird die bundesregierung im
vorliegenden fall die ermächtigung
erteilen
sie lässt es zu das strafverfahren gegen
ihn jan böhmermann satiriker und tv
moderator der grund dieses schnee
gedicht über den türkischen staatschef
erdogan sagte feige und verklemmt es
erdogan der präsident
sein gelöscht schlimm nach döner selbst
ein schweinfurts riecht schöner
er ist der mann der mädchen schlägt und
dabei gummimasken trägt nur erdogan
lachte nicht er tobte verlangte von
merkel den satiriker zu bestrafen eine
forderung die in deutschland in zeiten
des flüchtlings abkommens ein
politisches erdbeben auslöste merkel
verteidigt ihrer haltung die regierung
sei nicht für erdogan eingeknickt stadt
im rechtsstaat ist es nicht sache der
regierung sondern von
staatsanwaltschaften und gerichten die
persönlich das persönlichkeitsrecht und
andere belange gegen die presse und
kunstfreiheit abzuwägen
dennoch den umstrittenen gesetzes
artikel der majestätsbeleidigung will
die kanzlerin abschaffen frau und sony
hat es merkel das richtige getan
ich würde sagen ja und ich finde sehr
amüsieren das was sich jetzt der
öffentlich merkel verteidigen werde also
ich bin eigentlich merken sonst sehr
kritisch gegenüber jeder eu politik
selbst jahrelang über die möglichkeit
eine türkische eu antritt gemacht hat
abkommen finde überhaupt nicht okay und
ich finde auch überhaupt nicht okay wie
sie sich am anfang über die bühne mein
affäre geäußert hat wir sind die lizenz
also genau also das alles bin ich extrem
kritisch ich bin wirklich keine angela
merkel sein aber ich glaube die
entscheidung das verfahren zu erlauben
war genau die richtige entscheidung
es war die entscheidung zu sagen wir
sind hier einem rechtsstaat was heißt in
einem rechtsstaat zu sein die das
exekutive die regierung öffnen sich
nicht für einen freispruch also dieses
gesetz war damals wirklich dass
erlaubnis regierung von einer bewegung
zu entscheiden ob es wirklich einen
freispruch oder eine verurteilung gibt
heute nicht mehr und das ist wirklich
das ist wirklich die aussprache von
merkel
das ist nicht mein job ich sehe das
nicht so
es ist ja von erdogan auf zwei ebenen
geklagt worden
privatrechtlich selbstverständlich ja da
kann er einklagen und da wird das dem
rechtsstaat überlassen
und er hat sozusagen sich auf den
anderen paragrafen beruf auf der
sogenannten sechs beleidigungs paragraf
von dem so konstruiert ist dass damit
solch einer klage überhaupt stattgegeben
wird
zu den regierungsentscheid fällen muss
das heißt es ist keine delegation an den
rechtsstaat sondern es ist in dem fall
was ja ganz außergewöhnlich ist und
damit der geschichte des paragrafen zu
tun hat ist es tatsächlich so dass die
regierung entscheiden muss ob hier ein
rechtsverfahren überhaupt erst seinen
lauf nimmt es hätte genauso gut sagen
können nein es ist sozusagen gibt keinen
grund es gibt die freiheit der kunst
die hat hier priorität aber wenn er sich
beleidigt fühlt hat er natürlich die
möglichkeit seine privat klage
einzureichen die auch getan hat und ich
denke man muss das ganze jetzt schon
sehr sehen in den ganzen politischen
kontext was das für symbolische wirkung
hat und dass eine signalwirkung hat und
man kann einfach nicht übersehen dass
das auch die signalwirkung hat in der
sensiblen situation im verhältnis zur
türkei der flüchtlings abkommen wollen
wir jemanden nicht verärgern auch wenn
wir das sagen sehr kritisch gegenüber
stehen mögen und das 2 1 gemacht
das zweite ist das zweite ist es hat
auch das signal so zu sagen dass es zu
haus politische gründe gibt mit der
freiheit der kunst das ist schneller
schluss zu machen weiß man es vielleicht
glaubt aber also ich würde jetzt doch
viel eher favoriten hin zu stehen es ist
doch eigentlich eine viel geschicktere
weisweil sagt sie man muss es im
paragrafen abschaffen und weser
beantwortet das den gerichten weil das
eine furchtbar altertümliche
konstruktion ist das überhaupt die
exekutive sich einmischen aber nicht
mein problem ich über antwortet
gerichten nein aber dann
es ist klar das ist ja die große kritik
an frau merkel das ist eben sozusagen
das signalwirkung er gibt an die türkei
dass wir da niemanden verärgern wollen
aber man kann ja gleichzeitig sagen es
gibt eine signalwirkung auch im sinne
von bei uns ist es jetzt an sache der
gerichte die bei uns eben frei sind und
dann muss man ja sagen das ist also es
ist natürlich eine unangenehme situation
zunächst mal gewesen für angela merkel
aber sie hat sich darüber
daraus ja eigentlich mit den brillant
brillanten doppelschlag befreit also sie
hat sowohl die tödlich beleidigt als
auch die sache zurück an ihre gerichte
gegeben an eine wohl funktionierende
gewaltenteilung in ihrem spart man kann
das doch eigentlich als wirklich saubere
lösung bei ihren könnte es so sehen wenn
als philosoph sage das jetzt wenn nicht
ein logischer widerspruch drinnen ist
nämlich der genau darin besteht ich habe
die möglichkeit als regierungschefin zu
entscheiden ob jemand noch einen
paragraphen ein gerichtsverfahren
angehängt bekommt den ich im selben
atemzug eigentlich der überflüssiger
kläre
also wenn ich einen paragraphen nicht
mehr eingesetzt sind mehr für zeitgemäß
halte und ich hatte möglichkeit zu
entscheiden ob jemand noch diesen nicht
zeitgemäßen gesetz verfolgt oder nicht
dann müsste ich ja also wirklich
probleme mit der logik kam sozusagen
nicht einfach ein problem auftaucht sagt
naja ich erklärte paragrafen zu ungenau
danach sagen also jetzt gesagt sie hat
sie hätte nicht zeitgemäß aber sie hat
die möglichkeit aber wenn ich die
möglichkeit aber nicht zeitgemäßen
paragrafen gar nicht anwenden das kennen
wir in der inter juristerei totes recht
ja immer zwei sachen die nicht zeitgemäß
ich sind also lässt manches nicht
zeitgemäßen aber dass die regierung dass
das exekutiv so in entscheidungen
treffen darf das ist auch nicht
zeitgemäß ich und das ist genau was es
merkel gemacht als sie hat gesagt das
gesetz muss weg aber ich entscheide
nicht dass das gesetz nicht mehr geld
das machen wir anwerfen eine liberale
demokratie und ich entscheide diese
macht im alter graf mir gibt will ich
nicht benutzen
es ist nicht mein job wir müssen nur
kurz sie hat die macht natürlich benutzt
ja wenn ich die möglichkeit habe
zwischen a und b zu entscheiden dann
kann ich nicht sagen ich benütze gemacht
nicht wenn ich mich für ein scheide
sie hatte macht genügt sie muss das in
und ich glaube hier kein konsens aber
lassen wir uns doch darüber sprechen
warum ist das eigentlich ein so heißes
eisen jetzt geworden also auf
internationalem parkett breit diskutiert
es gibt natürlich in deutschland einen
großen aufruhr es gibt den herr stark
nicht meine kanzlerin
wir haben ganz viele deutschen sich luft
gemacht und gesagt sie zeigt sich
eigentlich erpressbar
die new york times hat am dienstag
geschrieben ist wird das falsche signal
gesendet merkel hat sich erpressbar
gemacht new york times und die britische
wochenzeitschrift spectator hat sogar
einen wettbewerb jetzt ausgeschrieben es
ist nämlich das oberste sportgericht
über den türkischen präsidenten man kann
tausendpfund gewinnen
wieso diese aufregung auf
internationalem parkett
sie haben ja schon diesen angetönt das
ganze feld in diesem kontext des
sogenannten ich nenne jetzt beim wort
die sloterdijk das nennt der teufelspakt
merkel hat einen teufelspakt geschlossen
und vor diesem hintergrund ist die ganze
sache schwierig ist es ein teufelspakt
sie erstmal die eu hat das geschlossen
wir sind da viel spaß deswegen glaube
ich wir haben hier eine stellvertreter
debatte also wir sollten darüber reden
was diese abkommen
eigentlich heißt und ich weiß es nicht
das heutige thema aber ich glaube leute
sind jetzt so sauer deswegen also
innerhalb es ist auch nicht zum beispiel
dass mir nicht zum beispiel klar dass
das merkel unbedingt diese entscheidung
aus den richtigen gründen getroffen hat
es kann wie möglich sein dass sie diese
entscheidung getroffen hat weil sie sich
unter druck gesetzt hat dass sie in
einem anderen fall das anders
entschieden
aber das problem ist das abkommen lass
mal über das abkommen reden also ich
meine jetzt nicht heute weil es nicht
unser ziel sollte mich etwas das mein
ich finde es ist einfach ja es ist eine
eine eine furchtbare lösung die eine
verletzung des internationalen rechts
und die tatsächlich auch merkel und die
eu unter druck setzen und ich finde auch
das ganze thema von eröffnung und und
von gespräche über einen einen eintritt
der türkei in die eu kommt zu später so
da glaube ich zum beispiel dass
deutschland auch eine historische
verantwortung hat also sie hätte vor
zehn jahren viel öffne gegenüber sein
soll und ich sage nicht wenn das
passiert wäre hätten wir heute nicht er
hat also ich glaube hier nicht darauf an
dass merkel im grunde genommen die
beitrittsverhandlungen mit der türkei
nicht aufnehmen wollte damals
genau als türkisch als die türkei
rechtsstaatlich an betrachtet in einem
viel gesunden zustand waren
ja genau also und ich meine klar dieses
ab also wenn wir es noch mal über die
stellvertreter debatte das ist ja glaube
ich eine debatte die gerade in
deutschland sehr moralinsauer geführt
wird also so kommt es mir vor meinem
gewissen giftigkeit weil wir natürlich
ich halte diesen deal diesen
menschenhandel oder teufelspakt uhr
herzlich zu zitieren auch für
hochproblematisch aber was wir im kern
ja doch als frage haben ist wie gehen
wir mit einer weltpolitischen
internationalen lage in der wir
natürlich zusammenarbeiten müssen
vielleicht nicht in dieser weise aber in
irgendeiner weise ja schon mit
regierungen mit ländern mit regimes die
nicht so sind wie wir es uns wünschen
und da gibt es natürlich und ich glaube
das kommt in dieser spott gedicht
geschichte ja auch recht gut zum
ausdruck
also es gibt natürlich schon auch also
böhmermann so richtig lustig war es ja
auch nicht es hat er ja schon ein
bisschen zu diesen diesen überheblichen
dunkel dieses nach unten also es ist ja
schon sozusagen also der verdacht des
primitiven dass ich meine so es war
hatte so keine selbstironisch in not ist
oder das wird natürlich auf aus
deutscher sicht darauf so zeit primitive
nicht dem stand der deutschen demokratie
entsprechende regime herunter geschaut
und natürlich muss man erdogan
kritisieren aber ich glaube in dieser
stimmlage ja dann vielleicht doch
wiederum auch nicht
ich glaube dass immer einige andere
aspekte ganz wichtig dass eine sich halt
dieses gedichten dessen auftrag für
böhmermann für unsäglich wirklich für
unsäglich ja aber nur weil ich jetzt
eine satire oder satire versuch für
unmöglich halte können jetzt sagen es
darf nicht sein dass wir doch gleich
ehrlicherweise würde zensur ein und
haben keine probleme
das zweite ist der ein unsägliches
gedicht über putin oder golfer der
nordkoreanischen diktator zum besten
gegeben worden und hätten die sich
aufgeregt hatten alle gelacht was sie
sich einbilden ja deutschland das jedoch
nicht vorschreiben was wir hier für
satire halten von irgendjemanden aus
nordkorea
wenn der aus istanbul konnte ich die
sache ganz anders aus das ist das und
das hat natürlich genau wie dieser
politischen konstellation zu tun wenn es
lothar rick von teufelspakt spricht weiß
wovon er spricht
das ist ein teufelspakt ich verkaufe
mirabeau ruhe und verschreibt dafür
meine seele darüber nachdenken wie die
sozusagen die die vertragsbedingungen
ihr tatsächlich sind und das dritte was
ich sagen wollte wir kennen doch diese
affäre nicht vollkommen losgelöst sehen
von all dem was seit den
mohammed-karikaturen seit charlie hebdo
auf diesem gebiet der politischen
diskussion über eine über satirische
aktionen durch die sich jemand beleidigt
gefühlt hat passiert ist das wäre doch
dann vollkommen scheinheilig wenn es ein
anderer trifft immer alle jazz wie
charlie dass immer alle solidarisieren
solidarisieren uns mit übrigens genauso
unsäglichen karikaturen und jetzt war es
habe so politisch opportun ist aber gar
kein problem damit zu sagen dass da
jetzt nicht sein und wieso lassen wir
das denken war alle einig es geht hier
um einen teufelspakt im hintergrund
unter anführungszeichen genau was wäre
wenn die alternative gewesen
hast du diese frage muss man ja schon
auch sie stellen also wir hätten doch
wieder über die flüchtlings weise die
airlines lässt sich nicht voneinander
trennen oder erreicht da gerade diese
ganze debatte warum sie so hochkocht ja
also jetzt kurz gesagt und das ist aber
auch keine verurteilung merkel war sehr
mutig am anfang vielleicht ein bisschen
zu mutig und sie hatte ein bisschen zu
schnell gemerkt so geht's nicht und dass
sie vielleicht doch in diesen themen
nicht genug leadership in europa sie hat
gehofft dass sie wieder so wirklich eine
es genau sie könnte ein vorbild sein und
das ist gescheitert aber nicht geklappt
mit dem organisieren
es gab auch gescheitert und gleichzeitig
aber wenn man schon geglaubt
organisieren glaubt immer das kostet
aber gleichzeitig wenn es darum geht zum
beispiel zum beispiel das dass wir auf
eu ebene auch was ressourcenverteilung
angeht vielleicht das problem angehen da
sie deutschland schwarz es gibt zum
beispiel auf dem tisch lösungen manche
finde ich überhaupt nicht gut aber es
gibt lösungen wieder das thema von
europe und zum beispiel zu erwecken um
die zu benutzen um die flüchtlingskrise
ein bisschen besser zu behandeln manche
sind schrecklich mag manche haben nur
den 6
noch mehr leute draußen verlassen aber
nicht alle
und da sind deutschland wiederum schwarz
deswegen wenn ihr noch einmal zur frage
zurück gehen macht satire politik oder
wie macht sie heute politik dann ist
eigentlich der verweis auf charlie hebdo
und auch die ganzen streitereien und die
mohammed-karikaturen ganz interessant da
man heute tatsächlich sieht satire
spielt natürlich immer stärker diese
trümpfe aus die sich aus diesen
spannungen zwischen sagen wir mal
säkularen und eher religiös geprägten
gesellschaften ergeben
aber das würde ich sagen es ist halte
ich auch für nicht unproblematisch aber
ich bin nicht sicher ob es jetzt in
diesem fall genau in diese richtung geht
weil natürlich dass erdogan jemand der
sozusagen religiösen islam vertritt muss
auch das land religiosität aber
letztlich geht es ja darum dass er eben
auch sozusagen in einen den rechtsstaat
in gewisser weise den demokratischen
rechtsstaat unterhöhlt hat in den
letzten jahren und es so zu sagen es
geht ihr eigentlich glaube ich in
richtung diktatoren schelte als in diese
richtung die wiederum probleme also zu
problematisieren auch ist dass man sich
sozusagen in europa denkt seiner
säkularen überheblichkeit gerne über
leute macht ihn auch deuce religiös sind
also das klar hat das so zu sagen es ist
so ein ein kontext aber ich glaube es
ist da doch noch mal zu unterscheiden
ich habe es nicht gemeint dass das
bewahren geschichte dazu sagen jetzt
religiöse gefühle beleidigt ja sonst gar
nicht mehr stellen aber jetzt gerade
haben sozusagen die gehen damit satire
um durch diese jemand beleidigt fühlte
erdogan hat sich auf diesen beleidigungs
paragraf nicht da ein ausländisches
staatsoberhaupt nicht beleidigen darum
geht's ja und dessen religiöse gefühle
verletzt sind auch satire da fühlt sich
auch beleidigt in seiner religion oder
weiß ein gott sozusagen geleitet worden
ist und was aber dass das philosophische
interessant oder ästhetisch interessante
ist ja das wesen der satire besteht nur
darin zu beleidigen ja also entweder
stehe auf dem standpunkt satire ist eine
form von kunst form zu deren wesen das
gehört zu beleidigen dann muss ich das
akzeptieren oder ich sag ich dazu in
jedem beleidigen und dann gibt es aber
auch dass satire
und dann gebe es sozusagen seiner
karikaturen noch ein kabarett das ein
bisschen schärfer ist noch hätte ich
dann die möglichkeit jemanden auf
satirische karikaturhaften art und weise
jemanden anzugreifen zu überzeichnen die
ganzen politiker karikaturen von denen
die kleinkunst letzten 30 jahre gelebt
hat könnte man streichen
ich hätte nichts dagegen ich wäre nur
für klare verhältnisse
also ich wollte auch noch kurz etwas zu
beginn einer fähre sagen also wenn die
bürger meiner ferien dazu führt dass das
gesetz abgeschafft wird prima das war
vielleicht auch eine der absichten aber
nicht die einzige aber ehrlich gesagt
muss ich sagen ohne jetzt den inhalt
verurteilen zu wahren und klar hätte das
machen dürfen
ich finde es ein bisschen schade ich
finde es wirklich einfach ein bisschen
schade als europäische bürgerin das ist
die aufmerksam von eine viel bessere
satire abgelehnt hat es war eine
reaktion auf diese extra 3 sowie erdogan
die eigentlich richtig richtig mächtige
satire war wie bin also einfach das
wichtigste instrument für satire benutzt
hat nämlich die wahrheit und ich finde
es jetzt ein bisschen schade dass jetzt
einmal zwei drei sätze dazu wie sie das
genau einbetten
sie spielen jetzt auf die vorgeschichte
sozusagen also es gab zuerst dieses lied
es gab dieses lied und erdogan hat auf
dieses lied erst mal reagiert und damals
gab es erstmal keine offizielle reaktion
von außen oder an und sorgen schon meine
reduzieren und dann gab es diese welle
von bürgern und was ist genau war weiß
ich nicht ob es seine art und weise war
die extra zu verteidigen
ob es ein bisschen eine nazis sache war
das weiß ich nicht ob es eine
provokation wenn wir diese extra 3 lied
besteht also es ist sehr witzig erst mal
das ist nur ein urteil ich finde es
witzig als bekümmern
aber es besteht nur aus waren aussagen
und das ist dass das grandios ist da und
das war halt diese ganze rahmenhandlung
diese dauernde metaebene dass man immer
wieder gesagt hat das ist jetzt ein
schneidiger darauf aber nicht
und das beispiel zeige ich jetzt was
noch nicht machen darf und so weiter das
war sozusagen der kniff um das genau
genommen
wir haben ja letztlich auch nur aus
unwahren aussagen bestanden also über
adwords alle möglichen eigenschaft von
der band ist so keine versicherung in
der realität haben wir sind fast am ende
unseres zweiten stammtisch angelangt wir
könnten noch lange darüber weiter
diskutieren aber jetzt ist es zeit für
unsere philosophischen tipps die wir
jeweils am ende eines philosophischen
stammtisch abgeben dessau newmark was
haben sie heute mitgebracht
also ich würde gerne die fil cologne
vorstellen
die beginnt am 17 mai und soweit ich
informiert bin hat jetzt gerade der
kartenvorverkauf begonnen in köln ein
philosophie festival bereits das vierte
ass vierte jahr hintereinander war sehr
schöne sehr breite eine ganze woche lang
kann man auf allen möglichen bühnen
philosophen beim denken und beim
diskutieren zuschauen zu den jeweils
aktuellen themen die sie gerade
beschäftigen also zu den aktuellen buch
erscheinungen lamberth wiesen über luxus
oder hartmut rosa und armen arbeiten
über beschleunigung und verlangsamen und
also zwei denke dann auch in den
konflikt bringen die ganz andere
vorstellungen von geschwindigkeit haben
und sehr sehr schöne konstellationen
diskussions konstellation auch ein sehr
schönes kinder und jugendprogramm und
wirklich einfach eine gelegenheit mal
denker sozusagen live und in farbe und
in einem schönen rahmen beim denken
zuzuschauen
also tickets kaufen und hinfahren wäre
ihr tipp verließ man sie haben wieder
ein buch mitgebracht ein dickes buch
diesmal ich bin so konventionell und
dieses buch hat durchaus mit unseren
heutigen stammtische zu tun denn einiges
was wir hier diskutiert haben wir
wirklich schwer im magen und anderes
muss ich erst verdauen und ganz ohne
davor ich gesprochen kann man auch
tatsächlich über verdauung und den bauch
philosophieren und ein kollege von mir
christian denker hat eine sozusagen
philosophie der verdauung geschrieben
das buch trägt den schönen titel vom
geist des bauches und es ist schon
erstaunlich wie philosophen von der
antike über das mittelalter bis zur
kenntnis und in die gegenwart immer
wieder ganz ohne davor ich diese frage
berührt haben die sehr beeinflusst diese
innerste physiologie der
nahrungsaufnahme des vertrauens des
ausscheidens tatsächlich auch unser
denken
also wer mehr von seinen damen fahren
will also mit charme schon erfahren hat
kann dieses buch vom geist des buches
auch noch nicht spielen an auf dem
bestseller damit schauen von der
frauenliste auch in der schweiz ein
grosses ein großer verkaufsschlager ist
aber hier also sozusagen die
philosophische unterfütterung des ganzen
oder überbaut über das wir je nachdem
frau und sony was ist ihr tipp ja ich
würde echt so gestehen ich habe es mir
ein bisschen überlegen müssen ich wusste
schon ich will einen philosophischen
blog empfehlen aber es gibt so viele
guten gerade in den fällen die moral und
politische philosophie das mainfeld ist
und ich muss auch ehrlich zu bestehen
ich hatte eine kleine die liberati
wunder mit einigen kollegen und am ende
zwar schwierige entscheidung aber ich
habe mich dafür entschieden just is
everywhere also dass titel des blogs
kommt aus einem spruch von martin luther
king of jazz anywhere i love ride to
justice aviva und es gibt eigentlich
darum das gleiche zu machen was wir
heute gemacht haben nämlich nicht
unbedingt bestimmte theorien zu
popularisieren sondern die instrumente
der philosophie zu benutzen um aktuelle
themen heranzugehen ihnen eine klarere
große art und weise aber auch also
relativ sogar jungs fähig es ist von
vielen jungen leuten geschrieben aus
verschiedenen ländern und akademischen
welt
das wird ein thema behandelt wie zb sind
finanzmärkte überhaupt merkte oder wie
kommt es dazu dass welle gegen ihre
eigene interesse wählen auch
interessantes thema für heute oder zum
beispiel tipps für leute die zum ersten
mal ein buch über politische philosophie
lesen wollen schreiben sie selber
filmburg nein eigentlich nicht aber gut
ich geguckt dazu gibt es glaube ich da
noch nicht alles so wie jetzt auch
nachts etwas koste aber wenn wir noch
nicht das könnte man vielleicht noch
nachtragen
ja das ist vielleicht ganz schön über zu
meinem tipp ich habe den neuen essay von
jahren werner müller mitgebracht was ist
populismus populismus ja ein großes
schlagwort gegenwärtigen jahren herr
müller der politik theorie in princeton
lehrt hatte ein eine auslegeordnung auch
an ideengeschichte des populismus hier
vorgelegt im container vor mit vielen
gillan es ist ja sehr auffallend dass
man im moment den populismus rechts wie
links als eine ganz große gefahr für die
demokratie sieht er frisst die
demokratie unterwandert die demokratie
aber es ist auch typisch dass wir gerne
einfach den politischen feind war als
populisten abkanzeln und in verruf
bringen und deswegen ist es wichtig sich
zu fragen was ist eigentlich ein
populist oder wer ist kein populist so
heißt nämlich auch eines der kapitel in
diesem buch und deswegen möchte ich
gerne dieses buch sehr herzlich
empfehlen
ja wir sind am ende dieses stammtisches
angelangt wir haben noch eine zwei
minuten zeit um zurückzublicken und
etwas ja vielleicht auffallend ist oder
was mir sehr auffällt werden hier auf
die debatten blicken die wir diskutiert
haben dass ich wie eine frage eigentlich
herauszukristallisieren scheint sowohl
in der bemerkt wenn man auch faire wie
bei den panama papers nämlich dieses
verhältnis zwischen nationalstaatlichen
denken und globalem denken und da frage
ich mich schon wie werden wir weiter
daran arbeiten hier am stammtisch aber
ganz generell gibt es da irgendeine idee
ihrerseits liege da irgendwie weiter in
die diskussion kommen könnten welche
welche möglichkeiten es gibt diese
zugkräfte aufzulösen
also ich glaube dass mittelfristig
natürlich an sozusagen transnationalen
konzepten im größeren stil kein weg
vorbeiführen wird weil ja nicht nur ist
dieser finanzproblem ist eine ganze
reihe anderer probleme von
nationalstaaten einfach nicht getätigt
werden können und die große gefahr ist
eben dass eine reihe dieser fragen
tatsächlich das national angegangen
werden und eine andere kategorie von
problemen nämlich dort wo es unangenehm
ist vielleicht doch etwas kostet wo
reibungsflächen wo konflikte entstehen
können an die ehemaligen sagen wir mal
eben alle nationalstaaten delegiert
werden
und das halte ich für die größte gefahr
dass wir nicht den selben fehler machen
die schon kleider globalisierung wir
internationalisieren die finanzmärkte
aber zum beispiel nicht das steuerrecht
und wir könnten vielleicht seit ich
meine das ist das hat nicht ganz
ernsthafte vorschlag von peter
sloterdijk dass wir eigentlich die
steuern ganz abschaffen sollten
und einfach jeder spendet gewisse reiche
menschen spenden ja gerne
dass sich jeder so wie diese globale
elite diese superreichen die sowieso in
kleinem nationalstaat sich mehr
verankern sondern herum chatten in der
welt als weltbürger versteht und dann
aber auch als weltbürger spendet und
zwar da wo es gut für gut befindet das
ist ein sehr liberaler sehr absurder
vorschlag in gewisser weise ja dazu
sagen ist das jetzt hat ihre ihrer seite
wenn sie das erste mal wirklich richtig
ernst aber letztlich in der gewisse form
des welt bürgertums kann man da dann
doch beobachten und vielleicht gibt es
da ein ansatz auch wenn man das erst mal
kritisiert doch manchmal weiter zu
denken wie wir uns selber auch als teil
von globalen gemeinschaft verstehen und
nicht nur nationalen frau und zog schon
ganz besorgt
ich wollte nur sagen ich habe eigentlich
nichts neues zu sagen also für mich ist
das sprichwort demokratie dass politik
auf globaler ebene oder supranationale
ebene unvermeidbar ist ist mir klar was
wir noch nicht wissen praktisch aber
auch theoretisch nicht ist wie wir das
demokratisieren wie wir genug
demokratische kontrolle und genug
demokratische partizipation an dieser
ebene haben können für mich ist das die
herausforderung nummer eins ohne geht es
nicht
und damit lasse ich es gut bleiben der
philosoph endlich der philosoph der die
stadt habe ich ihn schon zum philosophen
gemacht der dichter wilhelm busch hat
mal gesagt der philosophie ein
hausbesitzer hat dauernd reparaturen so
geht es uns auch ein bisschen aus wie
offen die probleme gehen uns nicht aus
wir bleiben dran
ich freue mich schon auf die nächste
debatte an diesem tisch ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für das mitdiskutieren
ja den nächsten philosophischen am
stammtisch gibt es am 12
juni die themen werden die darum ein
paar tage vorher bekanntgeben und wir
freuen uns wenn sie uns ihre fragen ihre
ideen dazu schicken
nächste woche begrüßt sie hier mein
kollege stephan klapproth mit einem
thema über das sie uns alle erreichen
können die bürokratie zu gast ist der
berühmte anthropologe david gray war
dann nicht nur die bürokratie sondern am
liebsten auch gleich den stab abschaffen
würde
und jetzt gleich geht es in der
sternstunde kunst nach köln zur familie
böhm eine dynastie von architekten die
in dritter generation zeichnet und baut
für kirchen heute moscheen und museen
und die vor allem auch ein
es ist nämlich eine ganz normale familie
schauen sie rein und genießen sie den
sonntag
[Musik]